Queen Lion is looking to make the elections
in her animal kingdom more fair.
Currently she divides her citizens into ranges
each of which selects one representative to
go to the jungle council which makes laws
for the kingdom.
But her citizens are unhappy, and it's easy
to see why: the council is full of monkeys.
Of course some of her citizens are monkeys,
but not all of them.
This council doesn't fairly represent her
kingdom.
Queen lion visits one of the ranges to find
out what's wrong and how to fix it.
In this range there five monkeys, four tigers,
three owls, two lynx and one buffalo.
One of each runs for representative and all
citizens vote for their own species.
The election rule is that the candidate with
the most votes wins, which is the monkey.
But it's a pretty unsatisfying result considering
that 2/3rds of citizens in this range *aren't*
monkeys and wouldn't vote for monkeys.
This is the same across all the ranges of
the kingdom, the monkeys have more votes than
anybody else, so they win all the elections,
even though they are a minority of the total
population.
Closer inspection reveals that the independent
advisors hired to draw the range boundaries
in the first place weren't as independent
as they first appeared.
The result is unhappy citizens who don't trust
the jungle council to make the fairest laws
for all, quite rightly.
Now Queen lion wants to maximize the number
of citizens happy with the election results.
One way to do that is to abolish the ranges
and use a proportional system...
...But her citizens *want* local representatives.
So Queen lion needs a system that both make
her citizens happier by having a more representative
council while keeping local elections in place.
After doing a little research she finds out
how: Single Transferable Vote.
The big change with STV is that ranges send
more than one representative, which may seem
weird, but queen lion decides to test it out:
she takes three ranges which used to each
send one representative and combines them
into one bigger range that will send three.
On election day citizens go to the polls and
the results in this new range are just the
same as they were in the old ranges: 34% for
Monkey, 33% for Owl and 33% for Lynx.
But this isn't most votes wins: with STV to
figure out the winners take the total votes
and divide by the number of representatives
needed, in this case 3 which gives 33% as
the amount a candidates needs to win.
So *all three* candidates go to the council
-- which accurately represents the citizens
in the range.
Whereas under the old system each range would
have sent a monkey.
Leaving 2/3rd of the citizens without representation.
A bigger range with more representatives allows
the range to be more proportional.
This test turned out well, but it was also
as simple as could be -- now Queen Lion wants
to see what happens in a race where not everyone
is a winner.
The next big range she tests has five candidates
running for office: Gorilla, Tasier, Monkey,
Tiger, and Lynx, three of which can be representatives.
Election day comes and goes, and here are
the results of citizens first choices:
Tasier gets 5%
Gorilla gets 28%
Monkey gets 33%
Tiger gets 21%
Lynx gets 13%
As before, a candidate needs 33% to win.
Monkey has that as so is immediately selected
as one of the three representatives.
But no one else reached the winning 33% so
how are the other two representatives selected?
Step one: get rid of the biggest loser.
Sorry tasier -- you really had no chance at
all.
Now, when the citizens voted, they could have
just put an X next to the candidate they liked
most but with STV they can also rank their
favorite candidates.
This is important because it shows how the
election would have turned out if one of the
candidates hadn't run.
Tiny and Worried Tasiers would have voted
for the big calm gorilla without tasier in
the race.
So if their candidate can't win, they want
their votes to go to Gorilla instead.
This pushes gorilla up to 33% and he become
the next representative.
Ranking allows citizens to support their favorite
candidate without worry -- there's no point
in strategizing about how everyone else is
going to vote.
The system works to maximize voter happiness
with the result.
Back to the range: there's still one representative
to select, so the next biggest loser is Lynx.
His voters don't like simians, but they do
think tiger's interests are similar to theirs
and so if Lynx can't win they want him to
have their votes.
Tiger gets reaches 33% and becomes the third
and final representative.
The election result looks pretty good especially
considering citizens first *and* second choices.
Now more citizens have a local representative
they can feel comfortable approaching, whereas
using the old system, everybody gets a monkey.
Lastly queen lion wants know what happens
in a range with just two political parties.
Under the most-votes-wins systems, multiple
candidates from the same party would be a
disaster: they'd split their voters and hand
the win to their opposition.
Queen lion makes one last test range with
2/3rd tigers and 1/3 gorillas that as before,
needs three representatives.
Because with STV citizens rank their candidates
there can be more than one candidate running
at the same time without any problems.
The tigers run two candidates as do the gorillas.
White tiger becomes the first representative,
but what happens next?
While tiger seems to be the biggest loser,
it's also obvious that he would have gotten
way more votes if white tiger wasn't in the
race.
If a candidate has more votes than they need,
like white tiger does, the first step is to
give the extra votes to their second choice.
This gets tiger to 33% and he becomes the
next representative.
If that seems strange, there are two things
to consider:
1) If instead the extra votes were ignored,
and tiger eliminated then the gorillas would
get the remaining two wins, which would obviously
not be represent the range.
2) Ignoring these 'extra' votes is punishing
citizens who backed the popular candidate,
which makes voters start thinking about how
everyone else will vote, rather than what
they really want.
If a candidate gets extra votes in the first
place it also means that those who voted for
him are a big section of the population and
thus fairly should get more representation.
Right: after the extra votes go to tiger,
the election finishes as before: Silverback
came in last, is eliminated and his voters'
second choice is the younger candidate so
gorilla gets in.
And the results are fair.
Queen Lion has now seen STV work.
Whether a range has one party or lots the
process is still the same:
1.
Citizens rank their favorite candidates.
2.
Any candidate above the threshold wins immediately,
3.
'Extra' votes go to their next choice.
4.
If no winner, last place is eliminated, and
the votes to go their next choice.
5.
Repeat until all the winners are found.
This whole this process is designed to maximize
the number of citizens who are happy with
the result.
This process gives STV has many advantages
over the old, most-votes-wins system:
1.
Citizens can honestly vote for their favorite
candidate without worrying about what everyone
else is going to do.
2.
It's more proportional.
So monkeying with the borders matters less.
3.
Almost all citizens will have a local representative
they actually voted for.
In the end Queen lion decides to switch the
council's elections to Single Transferable
Vote to make a better jungle council for all.